rejoignez-moi sur patréon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de la loi du
plus fort
la loi du plus fort c'est un sujet qui
fait couler beaucoup d'encre et qui
suscite généralement des débats très
animés le fait de savoir s'il est normal
que l'effort dominent les faibles le
fait de savoir s'il existe un droit du
plus fort or il se trouve que cette
question elle n'est pas du tout nouvelle
c'est une question qui a été beaucoup
discutée au 19e siècle notamment avec ce
qu'on a appelé le darwinisme social on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais c'est
aussi une idée qu'on retrouve chez
Nietzsche Nietzsche qui pensait que le
monde se divisait en deux catégories
d'individus l'effort et les faibles que
les forts étaient faits pour commander
et les faibles pour obéir
alors bien entendu c'est une vision qui
aujourd'hui nous paraîtra choquante
parce que dans la plupart des sociétés
contemporaines les rapports humains sont
régis par la loi or la loi elle est la
même pour tous qu'on soit fort ou faible
c'est même ça la raison d'être de la loi
maître tout le monde à égalité
mais malgré tout beaucoup de philosophes
se sont posés la question du droit du
plus fort que ce soit pour le défendre
ou pour s'y opposer et la première
référence qu'on trouve à ce droit du
plus fort elle date de l'antiquité à
travers un personnage qui s'appelle Cali
classe dans un texte de Platon qui
s'appelle le Gorgias
alors caliclès on ne sait pas trop si la
réellement existé ou pas il se pourrait
que ce soit simplement une création
littéraire de Platon parce que de les
appeler un personnage conceptuel un
personnage dont la fonction et
d'incarner une idée et donc dans le
Gorgias Platon va mettre en scène une
confrontation entre qualipless et
Socrate caliclès est en celui qui va
défendre la loi du plus fort tandis que
Socrate va au contraire défendre le
concept de justice
donc ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on se penche sur cette
confrontation et qu'on essaie de
comprendre les arguments avancés par
l'un et par l'autre pour savoir dans
quelle mesure il est possible de
justifier philosophiquement la loi du
plus fort
alors avant de se pencher sur les
arguments de qualités il faut expliquer
le contexte dans lequel s'inscrit cette
confrontation
le gorgiase c'est un texte qui a pour
sujet central la rhétorique la
rhétorique c'est-à-dire la persuasion
par le discours
Socrate combat la rhétorique il combat
la sophistique puisque pour lui
rhétorique et sophistique c'est la même
chose c'est l'art de la manipulation par
le langage c'est l'art de faire passer
le faux pour le vrai et le vrai pour le
faux et donc ce que veut montrer Socrate
c'est que la rhétorique est incompatible
avec la justice
parce qu'elle éloigne l'homme de ce vers
quoi il doit tendre à savoir la vérité
la vérité et la sagesse
pas d'accord avec Socrate parce que pour
Gorgias l'important n'est pas la vérité
l'important c'est le pouvoir
or la rhétorique donne du pouvoir
parce que comme on l'a dit la rhétorique
est un outil de persuasion
et donc celui qui maîtrise la rhétorique
peut faire agir les autres dans le sens
de ces intérêts
et quel plus grand pouvoir que celui de
faire faire aux autres ce qu'on veut
qu'il fasse
la rhétorique permet ça
donc la rhétorique a un pouvoir
transformateur sur le monde que la
simple action individuelle n'a pas
si par mémo je parviens à vous persuader
qu'il faut mélir président de la
République ou qu'il faut partir en
guerre contre tel ou tel groupe parce
que je vous aurais persuadé que ce
groupe représente une menace si je
trouve les bons mots ceux qui vont
appuyer sur les bons ressorts
psychologiques et que vous agissez
conformément à ce que je voulais vous
êtes sous mon pouvoir
c'est ça que dit Gorgias
et c'est ce contre quoi Socrate s'élève
Socrate s'élève contre ça parce que pour
lui utiliser le langage pour influencer
le comportement d'autrui c'est la
définition même de la manipulation
donc de l'injustice
et ce que Socrate veut montrer à Gorgias
c'est qu'un pouvoir injuste est un faux
pouvoir
parce qu'un pouvoir injuste ne peut
conduire qu'à du malheur
du malheur non seulement pour ce sur qui
ce pouvoir s'exerce mais aussi pour
celui qui l'exerce
le véritable pouvoir selon Socrate ce
n'est pas de manipuler les consciences
c'est de les élever
de les élever à la vérité
et c'est là que Cali classe va
intervenir
parce que pour cas les classes tout ce
que dit Socrate c'est juste des belles
paroles
des belles paroles totalement
déconnectées de la réalité
la réalité selon qualiclès c'est que la
vie est un rapport de force
la vie est une jungle
et pour survivre dans cette jungle tous
les coups sont permis
pour calices l'alternative est simple
soit on manipule soit on est manipulé
soit on domine soit on est dominé
soit on exerce le pouvoir soit on le
subit
la vision du monde de Cali classe c'est
une vision conflictuelle une vision
agonistique
à Gonne en grec c'est la compétition
la rivalité
et dans un monde régie par la
compétition il y a pas 50 solutions
soit on gagne soit on perd
pour qu'elle est classe la vision de
Socrate n'est pas tenable parce qu'elle
occulte la réalité profonde de la nature
humaine qui est la lutte
et que si on commence à vouloir suivre
des concepts aussi fumeux que le concept
de justice ou que le concept d'égalité
ou que le concept de vérité on est mort
sur le plan moral caliclès est un
conséquentialiste
il estime qu'on doit juger une action à
ses conséquences
tout ce qui me pénalise est mauvais
tout ce qui me favorise et bon
Socrate pense au contraire qu'une action
est bonne si elle est guidée par la
vertu
la vertu c'est quand nous agissons
conformément à ce qui est juste
indépendamment des conséquences
y compris même si ces conséquences sont
négatives pour nous
c'est pour ça que dans le Gorgias
Socrate dit qu'il vaut mieux subir une
injustice que la commettre
parce que quand on commet une injustice
on est coupable alors que quand on la
subit on est innocent
à choisir entre être coupable ou être
innocent Socrate choisi être innocent
et bien ça pour qu'elle classe c'est du
délire
du délire hypocrite
parce que dans les faits si vous
subissez une injustice vous aurez beau
vous dire que vous êtes du côté du bien
ça changera rien à votre situation
vous subirez quand même une injustice
et si celui qui est la cause de cette
injustice n'est pas punie s'il n'est pas
condamné et qu'on vient vous dire oui
mais il s'est puni lui-même en étant
injuste
ça vous fera une belle jambe
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ce punir
soi-même si on n'a pas en assumé les
conséquences concrètes
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ce punir
soi-même quand on est insensible à la
culpabilité
quand on a pas mauvaise conscience
tout le monde n'éprouve pas de mauvaise
conscience
donc l'idée que celui qui fait le mal se
condamne lui-même c'est de la foutaise
il y a des méchants heureux
il y a des innocents malheureux
donc pour caliclès la vision de Socrate
c'est une vision très naïve de la nature
humaine
et être naïf dans un monde hostile c'est
ce condamné à mort
pour qu'elle les classes le monde n'est
pas guidé par la justice
le monde est guidé par l'intérêt
donc entre commettre une injustice et la
subir pour qu'elle classe le choix est
vite vu
il vaut mieux la connaître
et si on peut la commettre sans en subir
les conséquences si on peut la commettre
avec impunité c'est encore mieux
parce que ce qui compte ce qui compte
réellement ce sont les faits
pour caliclès la justice en soi la
justice qui ne se traduit pas dans des
faits dans des condamnations dans des
réparations
elle ne vaut rien
le problème de Socrate c'est qu'il vit
dans un monde idéal ou plutôt dans un
monde idéal
dans un monde où ce sont les idées qui
règnent
elle classe lui ne vit pas dans un monde
idéal
il vit dans le monde réel
sur les idées et sur les idéaux
et ça ça fait une grande différence
on peut même dire que toute la
différence entre Socrate et calicless se
situe là
le rapport au réel
le statut du réel
et quand je dirais elle qu'on soit bien
d'accord je parle du réel au sens de ce
qui est factuel
au sens de ce que l'expérience nous
enseigne parce que petite parenthèse
conceptuelle pour Socrate le réel ce
n'est pas le monde matériel
ce qu'il appelle le monde sensible
parce que Socrate appelle le réel ce
sont les essences c'est à dire les idées
alors que pour que les classes au
contraire le réel ce sont les faits
les situations concrètes les motivations
concrètes
donc le désaccord entre Socrate et Cali
classe c'est un désaccord
épistémologique
un désaccord sur la hiérarchie entre les
faits et les normes
pour caliclès Socrate ne vit pas dans
les faits il vit dans les normes
il vit non pas dans ce qui est mais dans
ce qui devrait être
pour quelle classe Socrate est un
idéaliste
tandis que lui c'est un réaliste
un réaliste et un pragmatique
et quand on est réaliste on admet que ce
qui fait agir les êtres humains ce ne
sont pas des concepts
ce sont des motivations beaucoup plus
primitives le désert de conquête le
désir de domination le désir d'éliminer
la concurrence
peu importe que ce soit mal peu importe
que ce ne soit pas conforme à l'idéal de
justice c'est comme ça
la nature humaine est comme ça
et si la nature humaine et comme ça la
seule issue c'est la confrontation
la guerre de tous contre tous
une guerre dans laquelle la seule loi
qui tienne c'est la loi du plus fort
donc vous avez vu qu'en partant d'un
sujet qui était la rhétorique on en est
arrivé à la question du droit du plus
fort
étonnant
bah non pas étonnant
il y a un lien entre les deux
le lien entre les deux c'est la notion
de pouvoir
la rhétorique c'est un instrument de
pouvoir
et si le monde est régi par la
compétition celui qui maîtrise la
rhétorique à un avantage sur les autres
la rhétorique c'est une arme de
domination
on l'observe très bien dans nos sociétés
actuelles celui qui parvient à se hisser
au pouvoir ce n'est pas le plus juste ou
le plus compétent ou le plus honnête
c'est celui qui maîtrise le mieux l'art
de la rhétorique
l'art de l'apparence
l'art de l'illusion
se faire élire Président de la
République c'est d'abord être un bon
communicant
savoir mobiliser les bons affects
soigner son image
c'est fondamental l'image
si on élisait nos dirigeants uniquement
sur la base de programmes chiffrés avec
des listes de mesures écrites à l'encre
noire sur du papier blanc sans
exposition médiatique sans possibilité
de soigner son image ça changerait la
donne
d'ailleurs vous aurez remarqué que quand
on va voter les bulletins de vote sont
tous au même format
avec la même police de caractère
le principe des bulletins de vote c'est
l'égalité formelle
précisément pour ne pas influencer les
lecteurs
ce qui est évidemment le summum de
l'hypocrisie puisque tout ce qui précède
le moment de voter c'est à dire la
campagne médiatique est totalement
inégalitaire sur le plan formel
certains candidats ont des temps
d'exposition bien supérieur aux autres
il bénéficie d'une complaisance
médiatique que leurs concurrents n'ont
pas
ils ont reçu des heures et des heures de
médiatriding
et toute ces différences entre les
candidats toutes ces inégalités ce sont
des inégalités formelles qui influent
directement sur le résultat
on ne vote pas pour un candidat
on vote pour une image
pour un avatar
l'ironie de la chose étant qu'en
démocratie on est lit des représentants
c'est à dire littéralement des personnes
en représentation
tout ça ce n'est rien d'autre que la
forme aboutit de la rhétorique
c'est-à-dire de l'art de la persuasion
et qui fait que plus on maîtrise cet art
de la persuasion plus on a de pouvoir
qualiclès défend la rhétorique c'est
parce que la rhétorique nous fait
appartenir au camp des forts
la rhétorique c'est un des ingrédients
de la loi du plus fort
alors évidemment quand on pense à la loi
du plus fort on ne pense pas
spontanément à la rhétorique
même si effectivement ça en fait partie
la force linguistique
mais le 1er genre de force auquel on
pense
c'est bien évidemment la force physique
la force de coercition physique
par exemple en cas de conflit entre deux
individus
s'il y en a un qui fait deux fois la
taille de l'autre ou deux fois son poids
puisque c'est davantage le poids qui
fait la différence
mais disons entre deux individus
inégalement pourvu sur le plan physique
c'est le plus fort qui va l'emporter
et l'emporter ça veut dire soumettre le
plus faible
une bagarre c'est une lutte pour la
domination
une guerre c'est une lutte pour la
la différence entre la guerre et la
bagarre c'est que la guerre est une
lutte organisée
et généralement présentée comme
répondant à des motivations morales
mais celui qui remporte une guerre n'est
pas forcément le plus vertueux c'est
juste le plus fort
alors ça peut faire sourire de dire ça
parce que ça semble évident que celui
qui gagne une guerre c'est pas forcément
le plus vertueux
oui mais sauf que dans les faits celui
qui gagne une guerre c'est celui qui est
en position
d'imposer la légitimité de son statut de
vainqueur
c'est celui qui est en position de se
faire passer pour le vertueux
disons-le encore plus clairement
l'histoire est écrite par les vainqueurs
comme le disait l'historien américain
howardzin tant que les lapins n'auront
pas d'historiens leur histoire sera
racontée par les chasseurs
donc la force c'est ce qui institue
l'autorité
celui qui s'impose par la force c'est
celui qui est en capacité d'imposer le
respect de son pouvoir
et donc de fixer les règles
dans de nombreuses sociétés animales le
pouvoir est conditionné par la force
les chimpanzés se battent pour savoir
qui sera le chef le chef étant celui qui
a le contrôle des ressources
de ce point de vue là nous sommes restés
des primates
idem chez les Lions
idem chez les ours
idem chez les loups
c'est pas un hasard si clôte a écrit
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme
une phrase qui sera reprise par Rops au
XVIIe siècle qui en fera le substrat
anthropologique de sa théorie politique
parce que oui la vision de caliclès
c'est une vision qu'on va retrouver chez
de nombreux théoriciens politiques
modernes avec le concept d'état de
nature
et chez Ops l'état de nature l'état
originel de l'être humain c'est la lutte
et c'est pour sortir de cette lutte que
les hommes vont passer un impact pacte
social en créant l'État et les lois
donc si caliclès est un partisan de la
loi du plus fort
c'est parce qu'il observe que la loi du
plus fort c'est tout simplement la loi
de la nature
dans la nature on doit se battre pour
survivre on doit se battre pour se
nourrir ou pour se reproduire
quand on parle du contrôle des
ressources on ne parle pas seulement des
ressources alimentaires
on parle aussi des ressources sexuelles
la compétition sexuelle c'est quelque
chose de fondamental dans le règne
animal
et ça s'explique biologiquement de la
même façon que nous avons besoin de nous
nourrir pour survivre individuellement
nous avons besoin de nous reproduire
pour survivre collectivement
la sexualité c'est pas seulement un
plaisir
c'est d'abord un moyen de perpétuation
propager ces gènes c'est survivre
au-delà de soi
la sexualité n'est réduite au plaisir
que dans un monde où elle est décorée de
la fonction reproductrice
ce qui suppose la maîtrise de la
contraception
chose relativement récente à l'échelle
de notre histoire
mais d'un point de vue biologico animal
la sexualité ça sert à la reproduction
autrement dit se nourrir et se
reproduire
sa réponse à la même logique
la logique de la survie
le plus fort accapare la nourriture en
même temps qu'il accapare les ventres
donc si on récapitule pour caliclès la
nature nous offre le modèle à suivre
la nature nous met en compétition les
uns avec les autres en compétition pour
le pouvoir en compétition pour les
ressources et donc une société viable
pour qu'elle les classes c'est une
société qui comprend et qui reproduit
les lois de la nature
autrement dit qui est riche en loi
suprême la loi du plus fort
je disais au début de mon intervention
que la question de la loi du plus fort
avait été discutée au 19e siècle à
travers ce qu'on a appelé le darwinisme
social
le darwinisme social comme son nom
l'indique c'est l'application de la
théorie de Charles Darwin sur
l'évolution des espèces au domaine
social et politique
et notamment c'est l'idée que
l'évolution des sociétés humaines obéit
aux lois de la sélection naturelle
obi ou plutôt devrait obéir
le darwinisme social n'est pas seulement
une théorie descriptive
c'est une théorie prescriptive
c'est l'idée par exemple que la société
ne devrait pas protéger les plus faibles
qu'elle ne devrait pas combattre les
inégalités mais qu'elle devrait au
contraire laisser les individus se
livrer une compétition
parce que la compétition serait le
moteur du progrès
pour les darwinistes sociaux comme pour
caliclès toutes les lois visant à
protéger les faibles toutes les lois
visant à établir une égalité entre les
individus devrait être abolie
parce que l'égalité n'existe pas dans la
nature
parce que ce qui définit la nature c'est
l'inégalité
et que l'inégalité c'est le meilleur
vecteur de la sélection
et que si ça marche pour la nature ça
doit marcher pour la société
protéger les faibles favoriser les
faibles c'est affaiblir la société
vouloir légalité c'est vouloir le
nivellement par le bas
parce que l'égalité ne consiste jamais à
élever les faibles au niveau des forts
elle consiste toujours à abaisser
l'effort au niveau des faibles
elle consiste à faire de la faiblesse la
norme
et a demandé aux forts de se conformer à
cette norme
autrement dit dans une société
égalitaire
l'effort deviennent les esclaves des
faibles
les esclaves de la volonté des faibles
des faibles qui vont culpabiliser les
forts d'être fort qui vont construire la
condamnation morale et sociale de la
force et vont ainsi opérer ce que ninja
un renversement des valeurs
pour Nietzsche Socrate incarne
parfaitement ce renversement des valeurs
il incarne le renversement nihiliste de
la loi naturelle
remplacer la force par la justice
remplacer l'affirmation par la vertu
remplacer l'exaltation de la vie par la
culpabilisation
alors évidemment aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que ce schéma là le schéma
de la loi du plus fort est un schéma qui
ne peut plus s'appliquer dans nos
sociétés modernes d'ailleurs le plus
souvent c'est au nom de raison morale
qu'on rejette ce schéma on dira par
exemple qu'il est scandaleux d'envisager
les relations humaines en termes de fort
et de faible
en termes de dominant et de dominer
oui mais sauf que du point de vue de la
survie biologique
scandaleux ça veut rien dire
la survie biologique n'est pas une
affaire de morale c'est une affaire de
mécanisme
davantage et de désavantage de sélection
et d'élimination
éliminer les faibles c'est pas gentil
mais personne n'a dit que la nature
était gentille
donc la question n'est pas de savoir si
les scandaleux de prôner la loi du plus
fort la question est de savoir si c'est
pertinent
en d'autres termes
qualiclès a-t-il raison face à Socrate
quand il affirme que le monde est régi
par une compétition basée sur la force
et bien c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident et ce pour deux
raisons
la première raison c'est historiquement
la survie n'est pas qu'une affaire de
compétition c'est aussi une affaire de
coopération
d'entraide
je vous renvoie au livre du théoricien
anarchisteropodkine qui s'intitule
l'entraide un facteur de l'évolution et
qui montre bien que l'idée selon
laquelle la survie serait uniquement
liée à la compétition est un mythe
un mythe savamment entretenu par les
théoriciens capitalistes pour justifier
leur idéologie
en expliquant que la compétition ce
serait l'état naturel de l'humanité
et que donc le capitalisme c'est-à-dire
la compétition entre les agents
économiques ce ne serait rien d'autre
que le prolongement de la compétition
biologique
gros pote qui ne montre au contraire que
chez l'être humain comme chez de
nombreux espèces animales la coopération
a constitué un facteur déterminant dans
l'évolution
donc ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que même dans
une conception du monde fondée sur la
compétition la force entendue au sens de
force physique
n'est qu'une modalité parmi d'autres de
la compétition
autrement dit on peut dominer par autre
chose que par la force
qualification lui-même nous en a donné
un exemple la rhétorique la rhétorique
c'est un moyen de dominer qui ne repose
pas sur la force
on peut également parler de la
domination par l'argent
dans une société capitaliste les riches
n'ont pas besoin d'être physiquement
fort pour dominer
la puissance financière confère un
pouvoir que la puissance physique ne
confère pas
on a aussi la puissance relationnelle
c'est à dire le réseau
la puissance intellectuelle
tout ça ça joue énormément dans les
rapports de domination
et dans l'Occident moderne ce sont ces
puissances là qui sont à l'oeuvre
la puissance physique a été très
largement démonétisée
celui qui cultive sa force physique de
nos jours à plus de chances de passer
pour un bourrin que pour un homme de
pouvoir
parce que le pouvoir moderne c'est
l'influence
et que l'influence ne passe pas
nécessairement par la force
entre le PDG de Google et un champion de
MMA celui qui a le plus de pouvoir c'est
le PDG de Google
donc si la force physique à
effectivement constitué un avantage
évolutif certain dans l'histoire de
l'humanité force et d'admettre
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas
ou en tout cas que ce n'est plus ça le
critère déterminant dans les relations
de pouvoir
et ça ça s'explique par des raisons
contextuelles
dans un contexte de rareté des
ressources dans un contexte où il faut
littéralement se battre pour survivre la
force à un intérêt
mais dans un monde régit par d'autres
lois dans un monde où l'accès aux
ressources passe par un intermédiaire
qui est l'argent être fort et beaucoup
moins avantageux qu'être riche ou
intelligent
donc les leviers de la domination n'ont
pas disparu
ils se sont simplement déportés
et il se rattache désormais à des
qualités qui ne sont pas d'ordre
physique mais d'ordre symbolique
et c'est là qu'il faut apporter une
précision fondamentale
parce qu'en réalité parler de loi du
plus fort
cette trompeur justement parce que la
force n'est qu'un critère parmi d'autres
de la sélection naturelle
en réalité il ne faudrait pas parler de
loi du plus fort
il faudrait parler de loi du plus apte
chez Darwin les individus qui survivent
ce ne sont pas les plus forts
ce sont les plus aptes
les plus adaptés
les plus adaptés à quoi alors
environnement
les dinosaures étaient sans doute
l'espèce animale la plus forte avant de
disparaître
ça les a pas empêché disparaître
parce qu'il n'était plus adapté
dans certains environnements une grande
taille ou une grande masse constitue un
désavantage évolutif
parce qu'une grande taille suppose des
besoins énergétiques supérieurs
et qu'avoir des besoins énergétiques
supérieurs c'est être plus facilement en
proie au manque
et ça vaut également pour les êtres
humains
quelqu'un qui a une constitution
physique faible mais qui a les moyens
financiers de se payer des soins c'est
quelqu'un qui a davantage de chance de
survivre que celui qui a une meilleure
constitution physique mais qui n'a pas
les moyens de se payer des soins
en cas d'accident ou en cas de maladie
le plus riche va survivre
le plus fort va y rester
donc on parlait tout à l'heure du
darwinisme social le darwinisme social
ne prône pas la loi du plus fort
il prône la loi du plus apte
et la force n'est qu'un facteur parmi
d'autres de l'adaptation
vous connaissez peut-être cette remise
de prix parodique les Darwin Awards les
Darwin Awards c'est un concours qui
récompense les individus qui se sont
illustrés en mourant de manière
particulièrement stupide
comme par exemple cet homme qui a voulu
filmer des parachutistes et qui a sauté
de l'avion sans porter lui-même de
parachute
ou celui qui est mort étouffé en voulant
prouver qu'il pouvait avaler un
cheeseburger en une seule bouchée
ce concours s'appelle les Darwin wards
parce que mourir aussi bêtement c'est
faire le travail de la sélection
naturelle
la sélection naturelle qui ne tient pas
seulement compte de la force mais de
l'intelligence
donc parler de sélection des plus forts
ce n'est pas la même chose que parler de
la sélection des plus aptes
et d'ailleurs c'est là-dessus que
Socrate va coincer qu'à les classes
en réalité il va le coincer sur deux
choses
la première c'est le fait que caliclès
prétendait être pour la loi du plus fort
alors que dans le même temps il prône
l'usage de la rhétorique
or la rhétorique c'est le fait de ne pas
défendre ce que l'on pense soi-même
c'est le fait de conformer son discours
aux attentes du public
autrement dit de se laisser dicter son
opinion par la majorité
or le fort est-ce que ce n'est pas au
contraire celui qui impose ses idées
ou en tout cas qui les assument
adapter son discours à la majorité se
conformer à la majorité
n'est-ce pas une attitude de faible
donc ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose sur laquelle Socrate
va coincer qu'elle est
c'est quand il lui demande de quel côté
se trouve la force entre le grand nombre
et le petit nombre
et évidemment que les classes lui répond
du côté du grand nombre
parce que plus on est nombreux plus on
est fort
ces mathématiques
mais dans ce cas-là ça veut dire qu'une
majorité d'individus faibles et plus
forte qu'une minorité d'individus fort
autrement dit en voulant prenez la loi
du plus fort
caliclès finit par admettre que la force
se trouve du côté des faibles
elle est là la contradiction
parce que si la force se trouve du côté
du grand nombre ça veut dire qu'être
pour la loi du plus fort c'est être du
côté des faibles coalisés contre les
forts
c'est logique
soit on est pour la loi du plus fort
sont les pas
et donc la réponse de Socrate à caliclès
c'est qu'il fallait pas choisir le
critère de la force
parce que c'est un critère qui se
retourne contre lui-même
alors oui dire que les faibles sont
obligés de se coaliser contre l'effort
pour rivaliser c'est vrai
mais il n'empêche qu'en se coalisant les
faibles deviennent plus forts que les
forts
donc faut pas venir se plaindre
puisque c'est toi qui a instauré le
critère de la force
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces partisans de
la loi du plus fort qui chouine parce
qu'ils se font battre par les plus
faibles
c'est pas cohérent
le fort c'est celui qui doit assumer le
fait que les faits se coalise contre lui
c'est celui qui ne peut pas se plaindre
du fait que les faibles réagissent
et donc quand qualithèse accuse les
faibles de vouloir culpabiliser l'effort
avec leurs morales exactement ce que
fera Nietzsche 2300 ans plus tard quand
Nietzsche parlera de la morale
d'esclaves de la morale du ressentiment
c'est-à-dire de la morale créée par les
faibles pour se protéger d'efforts il ne
se rend pas compte que faire ça c'est
prenez la loi du plus fort avec une
mentalité de faible
c'est dire les faibles sont méchants ils
se coralise contre moi
bah oui
tu t'attendais à quoi
les faibles sont méchants il me
culpabilise d'être fort
c'est ça être fort
c'est se sentir culpabiliser par les
faibles
mais si tu es si fort que ça comment ça
se fait que tu te sentes menacé par la
morale des faibles
comment ça se fait que tu te soucis de
ce que pensent les faibles
pourquoi est-ce que tu ne te contentes
pas de les ignorer
pourquoi ce besoin d'accuser les faibles
est-ce que ce ne serait pas précisément
ça la morale du faible
quelle classe c'est l'enfant qui tape un
autre enfant plus faible que lui et qui
pleure parce que le grand frère vient
lui mettre une trempe
est-ce que le partisan de la loi du plus
fort voudrais qu'on instaure une règle
qui interdit au faible de se défendre
instaurer des règles est-ce que ce n'est
pas précisément ça que dénonce l'effort
et c'est cette contradiction qui va
pousser calliplès a changé son fusil
d'épaule
à dire que ce qu'il prône en réalité ce
n'est pas la loi du plus fort mais c'est
la loi du meilleur
et par meilleur
qualiclès veut dire celui qui donne
libre cours à ses passions
celui dont la vie consiste à satisfaire
tous ses désirs
pour qu'elle classe le modèle de vie à
suivre c'est le modèle de
l'individualisme hédoniste
alors ça c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est le moment de la
confrontation ou l'argumentation va
bifurquer
puisque la question ne va plus être de
savoir est-ce qu'il faut que les plus
forts dominent mais qu'est-ce qu'une vie
heureuse
parce que pour Socrate aussi bien que
pour qualithèse le modèle moral à suivre
c'est celui qui favorise le bonheur
or sur la question du bonheur leur
conception s'affrontent
la conception de Socrate c'est qu'une
vie heureuse est une vie de tempérance
une vie de modération
pour Socrate être heureux ne consiste
pas à satisfaire tous ces désirs mais au
contraire à les maîtriser
parce que le désir c'est le manque
et le manque c'est ce qui perturbe
l'équilibre de l'âme
c'est l'accarait la fameuse image du
tonneau percé le tonneau percé étant la
métaphore de l'âme insatisfaite de l'âme
perforée par le désir et bien pour
Socrate vivre avec une âme insatisfaite
c'est ça être malheureux
la conception de caliclès c'est tout le
contraire
pour quelle classe une vie heureuse
c'est une vie de désir
il le dit explicitement une vie sans
désir ce n'est pas une vie
c'est la mort
une vie sans désir c'est le contraire de
la vie
donc pour qu'elle iclès que le désir
soit comme un trou dans l'âme et qu'il
faille le remplir sans cesse en allant à
la conquête de toujours plus de plaisir
c'est pas un problème
puisque c'est ça l'essence de la vie
on va le dire autrement la différence
entre Cali classe et Socrate c'est que
pour caliclès le manque est positif
l'insatisfaction est positive
puisque la jouissance qu'on obtient en
assouvissant ses désirs et la sensation
la plus agréable qui nous soit donné des
prouver
chez Socrate le manque et ce qui
perturbe l'âme
chez kaliklès c'est une force vitale
puisque c'est le mot qui fournit
l'énergie pour combler le manque
on a vu tout à l'heure que la loi du
plus fort reposée sur l'idée que le plus
fort c'est celui qui est le plus apte à
dominer
et que dominer c'était le meilleur moyen
de contrôler les ressources vitales
donc il n'y a pas de problème avec le
manque il n'y a pas de problème avec
l'insatisfaction puisque
l'insatisfaction produit en réaction
l'énergie pour la compenser
et la vie ce n'est rien d'autre que le
mouvement entre le manque et la
satisfaction du manque qui sont les deux
pendant de la vie
il y a vie parce qu'il y a manque et
moyen de satisfaire ce manque
la vie est un pendule
une oscillation
une oscillation entre désir et
jouissance
entre manque et satisfaction du manque
et nier ça saigner le mouvement de la
vie elle-même
saigné l'inconstance fondamentale de la
vie
et le fait que cette inconstance n'est
pas un problème mais qu'elle doit
seulement être acceptée comme doit être
accepté le fait que les relations
humaines sont régies par la lutte
pour caliclès la vie c'est le mouvement
et le mouvement génère la lutte
la lutte est une conséquence du
mouvement
la compétition est une conséquence du
désir
la réponse de Socrate c'est que ça c'est
une fausse vision
c'est la vision de quelqu'un qui n'a pas
compris que le mouvement pouvait être
stabilisé
c'est la vision de quelqu'un qui n'a pas
compris qu'il était possible de ne pas
être soumis au balancier du désir
parce que l'être humain possède en lui
la raison
il possède en lui la capacité à la
modération
autrement dit l'être humain n'est pas
condamné à être l'esclave de son désir
il peut le maîtriser
il peut le réguler
pour Socrate nous ne sommes pas obligés
d'obéir au mouvement naturel
nous pouvons le maîtriser
et maîtriser le mouvement naturel ce
n'est pas elle est contre la nature
mais c'est au contraire accomplir notre
nature d'être raisonnable
maîtriser la nature c'est faire ce que
la nature a prévu pour nous
ne pas chercher à devenir raisonnable ne
pas chercher à dépasser la loi du plus
fort c'est ça aller contre la nature
parce que c'est ne pas exploiter cette
possibilité que nous a offert la nature
qui est la possibilité de nous améliorer
nous améliorer en nous émancipant de
notre dimension primitive
s'améliorer c'est élever son âme
l'élevé vers l'esprit
c'est se détacher des dépendances
matérielles
les désirs sensuels tu désires de
domination de lubrisse
la nature de l'être humain c'est la
perfectibilité
c'est à dire le fait de pouvoir devenir
meilleur
et devenir meilleur ça passe par créer
les conditions d'une vie harmonieuse
d'une vie vertueuse plutôt que d'une vie
chaotique
la nature humaine selon Socrate ce n'est
pas le chaos
et cet ordre peut et doit se refléter
dans nos lois
qu'en caliclès dit que nos lois sont une
pure invention un pur artifice
Socrate répond que les lois s'auto
contraires la traduction de notre nature
fondamentale qui est de sortir de notre
animalité
l'animalité n'est pas notre destination
elle est notre provenance
le but ce n'est pas de viser notre
provenance
nous y sommes déjà
c'est de viser notre destination
et cette destination Socrate lui donne
un nom
la justice
la justice c'est ce que doit viser
l'homme pour accomplir sa nature et
ainsi accéder au bonheur
la différence entre Socrate et
qualicless elle est finalement très
paradoxale à savoir que c'est celui qui
pense que le monde se définit par le
mouvement quelle classe qui pense qu'il
faut rester figé dans notre animalité
tandis que c'est celui qui pense que le
monde se définit par la fixité Socrate
qui pense qu'il faut faire un mouvement
en dehors de notre animalité
pour quelle classe la vie est une jungle
et il faut l'accepter
pour Socrate la vie est une jungle
Façonnable par la justice
je cite
les lois sont faites pour les faibles et
par le grand nombre c'est pour eux et
dans leur intérêt qu'il les font et qui
distribuent les éloges ou les blâmes et
pour effrayer l'effort ceux qui sont
capables d'avoir l'avantage sur eux pour
les empêcher de l'obtenir ils disent
qu'il est honteux et injuste
d'ambitionner plus que sa part et que
c'est en cela que consiste l'injustice à
vouloir posséder plus que les autres
quant à eux j'imagine qu'il se contente
d'être sur le pied de l'égalité avec
ceux qui valent mieux que voilà pourquoi
dans l'ordre de la loi on déclare
injuste élève l'ambition d'avoir plus
que le commun des hommes et c'est ce
qu'on appelle injustice mais je vois que
la naturelle même proclame qu'il est
juste que le meilleur est plus que le
pire et le plus puissant que le plus
faible elle nous montre parmi l'exemple
qu'il en est ainsi et que non seulement
dans le monde animal mais encore dans le
genre humain dans les cités et les races
entières on a jugé que la justice
voulait que le plus fort commanda au
moins fort et fut mieux partagé que lui
de quel droit en effet exerce porta-t-il
la guerre en Grèce et son père en City
sans parler d'une infinité d'autres
exemples du même genre qu'on pourrait
citer mais ces gens-là je pense agissent
selon la nature du droit et par Zeus
selon la loi de la nature mais non
peut-être selon la Loi établie par les
hommes nous formons les meilleurs et les
plus forts d'entre nous que nous prenons
en bas âge comme des lions sauts pour
les asservir par des enchantements et
des prestiges en leur disant qu'il faut
respecter l'égalité et que c'est en cela
que consiste le beau et le juste mais
qu'il paraissent un homme d'une nature
assez forte pour secouer et briser ses
entraves et son échapper je suis sûr que
Foulon au pied nos écrits nos prestiges
nos incantations et toutes les lois
contraires à la nature il se révoltera
et que nous verrons apparaître notre
maître dans cet homme qui était notre
esclave et alors le droit de la nature
brillera dans tout son éclat
prenez la loi du plus fort
c'est vouloir ériger en loi
l'absence de loi
c'est vouloir ériger en droit
l'absence de droit
et surtout
c'est réduire l'éventail des facultés
humaines à une seule
celle que nous avons en commun avec les
animaux
l'homme est un animal
mais c'est un animal
conscient d'être un animal
c'est un animal capable de s'élever
au-dessus de son instinct et de dire je
suis plus qu'un animal
mon instinct me constitue
il me pousse à manger quand j'ai faim à
boire quand j'ai soif
c'est un allié de ma survie
mais quand ma survie n'est plus en jeu
comme on existence ne se résume plus à
une lutte pour la survie
je deviens
animal conscient
je deviens être humain
un être capable de transformer le monde
de partager le fruit de mes conquêtes
de protéger les faibles des prédations
des forces
je deviens un être soucieux du groupe
et qui met sa force à son service
car si les deux notre devoir de suivre
les lois de la nature
gardons à l'esprit que la nature a fait
de nous
des êtres capables de donner et
osons le mot
capable d'aimer
je vous remercie
[Musique]